ah i think when i was a kid that i was
advised that the and this is poverty
depression thinking somebody said there
was a there was a job in limerick where
I grew up and at the time cars were not
as as numerous as they are now there
were more horses and so they dumped
their their horse shit all over the
place and there was a few people got
jobs in Limerick a big barrel on wheels
it was a battle went back and forth and
a shovel and a broom so they went around
shoveling the horse shit into this into
this barrel so you got that job when
you're about 15 and then you've got to
retire at the age of 65 with the pension
small pension so that would be 50 years
of shoveling horse shit and I was
advised very seriously that I should get
that job and take heart that now that's
it that's either here on this earth
shoveling horse shit or else it's my
punishment in hell shoveling horse shit
and that's the worst advice I ever got
and the best advice was to whatever you
want because that's not what you are
that's what you do for the moment
you